die meisten von euch haben es
wahrscheinlich irgendwo mitbekommen
letzte woche ist die aktie von gamestop
explodiert quasi von heute auf morgen
hat sich die bewertung des unternehmens
verzwanzigfacht und ja wir reden hier
von gamestop dem laden wo man physische
spiele discs für teures geld kaufen und
dann dieselben spiele für einen
bruchteil davon auch wieder verkaufen
kann der gamestop wie ihr euch
vielleicht vorstellen könnt befindet
sich das unternehmen in zeiten von
corona und digitalen spiele downloads
und nicht gerade in der besten lage
wieso kaufen also gerade alle gamestop
aktien fragt ihr euch
weil internet oder genauer gesagt weil
reddot mein liebstes social network noch
vor twitter
dies ist die geschichte davon wie ein
nutzer auf 50.000 50 millionen us dollar
gemacht hat wie sich ein internetforum
zusammentut um es den großen hedgefonds
der wall street zu zeigen und davon wie
diese geschehnisse vielleicht den
aktienmarkt für immer verändern könnten
wenn die bisher bei den ganzen shorts
patches und squeeze ist nicht so ganz
durch gestiegen sei kein problem ich
versuche in diesem video mal so einfach
wie möglich zu erklären was hier
passiert ist also lehnt euch zurück
haltet euer aktienportfolio fest und los
geht's
[Musik]
achtung ich bin kein finanzberater und
ich gebe hier keine aktientipps das ist
reine unterhaltung hier wenn überhaupt
kann ich euch nur davon abraten jetzt
noch im gamestop zu investieren sei zwar
mit eurem geld und selbst immer nur so
viel ein wie er auch bereits seite zu
verlieren so wie im casino diese
geschichte beginnt schon im september
2009 10 ein raid user mit dem namen die
pak in value hat über 53.000 us dollar
in aktien von gamestop investiert und
postet sein investment im sub great wall
street betz der preis damals um die 4
dollar pro aktie wall street betz ist
ein ort an dem leute ihre wetten auf dem
aktienmarkt ihre gewinne und vor allem
ihre verluste posten und sich andere
leute darüber lustig machen es ist ein
wiens hat er unterhaltung als alles
andere
und so wird die pak in value natürlich
ausgelacht gamestop im jahr 2019 wo die
meisten games gedownloadet werden steigt
besser schnell aus aber die pak in value
hat einen plan was zu dem zeitpunkt
nämlich noch keiner weiß er ist
finanzberater youtuber der sich mit spox
auseinandersetzt und hat das unternehmen
ganz genau analysiert dabei ist er zu
dem schluss gekommen dass gamestop unter
marktwert gehandelt wird
die pak in value bzw mohring kitty wir
auf youtube eigentlich heißt hat seine
hausaufgaben gemacht und er hält an
seinen aktien fest regelmäßig postet er
im wall street betz den aktuellen stand
seines investments auch wenn es direkt
zu beginn erst mal bergab ging er 15.000
dollar an einem tag verlor und von allen
ausgelacht wurde die pak in value hielt
und das hat sich bezahlt gemacht ein
jahr später stieg ein großer investor in
gamestop ein und begann einige positive
veränderungen in die wege zu leiten
denn stoff will sich neu erfinden den
digitalen shop verbessern partner dafür
mit microsoft und die zukunft von
gamestop sieht auf einmal gar nicht mehr
so schlecht aus der preis des sterbenden
gamestop lag jetzt bei ca 10 dollar pro
aktie
andere user im thread sahen die
regelmäßigen post von deep fucking value
und bemerkten dass er dabei war richtig
viel geld zu verdienen
er hat zwischendurch während der korona
krise und einigen sehr schlechten
quartalen tatsächlich noch mal
nachgelegt und ein jahr nach seinem
ersten post hatte er schon über eine
million dollar gemacht
schnell bildete sich ein
um ihnen kann man gar nicht anders sagen
er wurde als zeitreisender bezeichnet
und als gott es gibt eine menge - die
alle super witzig sind und leute auf
reddit begannen seine investments zu
kopieren
sie begannen auch gamestop aktien zu
kaufen was den preis natürlich weiter
steigen ließ aber dann passierte etwas
spannend ist ein großer hedgefonds an
der wall street haben gegen gamestop
gewettet sie haben die aktie geshortet
hedgefonds sind folgendes da kann man
sein geld anlegen und die verwalten das
dann für einen und zwar mit besonders
risikoreichen und spekulativen
strategien wie zum beispiel short
selling im deutsche nennt man das auch
leer verkauft aber was bedeutet shorty
nun ich weiß dass es nicht so ganz
leicht zu verstehen ist aber ich
versuch's mal anhand eines beispiels zu
erklären bleiben wir doch einfach mal
beim gamestop szenario und sagen dass
marian hier mir ein spiel aus leitung
zum beispiel fifa hier ist gerade etwas
anderes willst du mein fifa haben du
musst es mir nur in drei monaten wieder
geben ok danke dafür gebe ich den
nächstes mal einen aus jetzt gehe ich
aber hin und zog das spiel gar nicht
sondern verkaufen das auf ebay für sagen
wir mal 50 euro unter freunden jetzt
nicht so cool das geliehene spiel zu
verkaufen um auf dem aktienmarkt ist das
tatsächlich erlaubt und dafür gebe ich
marian ja auch eine kleine summe geld
dann warte ich drei monate und hoffe
dass fifa bis dahin günstiger zu haben
ist bei games ist das ja generell der
fall dass sie mit der zeit etwas
günstiger werden
deswegen sagen wir mal ich hab glück
kaufe fifa drei monate später für nur 30
euro jemand anderen auf ebay ab und gebe
marian das spiel zurück die 20 euro
unterschied von 30 auf 50 die stecke ich
mir in die tasche das ist mein gewinnen
das ist short selling es ist das wetten
darauf dass ein preis fallen wird es ist
quasi das gegenteil vom normalen
aktienkauf weil man gegen die firma ist
die mannschaft
man hofft dass sie im optimalfall pleite
geht denn dann sind die aktien wertlos
ich müsste gar nichts zurückgeben und
ich habe 100 prozent gewinn gemacht
ob shopping jetzt gut oder schlecht ist
darüber streiten sich die gelehrten es
gibt definitiv positive aspekte davon
aber gerade hedgefonds stürzen sich oft
auf schwächelnde unternehmen und üben
durch ihre shorts zusätzlichen druck aus
was natürlich mega asozial ist wenn du
eh schon probleme hast mit deiner firma
und die geht dann pleite weil die man
mit viel geld gegen dich gewettet hat
nur um selber damit geld zu verdienen
jetzt aber was spannendes passiert
gamestop wurde von hedgefonds nicht nur
geshortet
sondern überschattet das bedeutet dass
mehr aktien geshortet wurden als
überhaupt aktien von gamestop im umlauf
sind
das sollte eigentlich nicht passieren
man könnte das jetzt so interpretieren
dass sich die hedgefonds so sicher waren
dass gamestop irgendwann pleite geht
dass sie ein bisschen zu gierig geworden
sind und sich damit angreifbar gemacht
haben und genau das wollten die reddot
user ausnutzen denn jetzt geht es
richtig los
immer mehr leute auf wallstreet betz
investieren in gamestop und lassen so
den preis in die höhe schnellen
sie wollen den hedgefonds der wallstreet
eins auswischen und damit auch selber
geld verdienen denn das gefährliche an
short selling ist der potenzielle
verlust ist theoretisch unendlich bei
einer normalen aktien sagen wir mal
wirecard kann ich maximal 100 prozent
meines investments verlieren
ich kaufe eine aktie für 100 euro der
vorstandsvorsitzende von wirecard ist
ein betrüger und schwupps ist mein aktie
nichts mehr wert wirklich so passiert
aber beim short selling kann ich
theoretisch unendlich viel geld
verlieren denn ich muss die ausbildende
aktien die ich ja gerade nicht habe
zurückgeben sie gehört mir nicht und das
bedeutet dass ich sie irgendwann kaufen
muss egal für welchen preis
bleiben wir bei liefer sagen wir es
wurde ein bug oder sowas entdeckt und es
werden plötzlich keine neuen fifa discs
mehr hergestellt das steigt also der
wert einer disco auf das doppelte oder
sogar das dreifache an
aber ich muss ja maria nach drei monaten
sind vielfach zurückgeben egal was ist
das habe ich ihm versprochen
ich muss also in den sauren apfel beißen
und die plötzlich für 150 euro
fifa besorgen 100 euro verlust für mich
und wenn wir uns jetzt vorstellen dass
jemand alle discs von fifa auf ebay
aufkauft da kann er quasi jeden
beliebigen preis von mir verlangen
ich muss ihnen bezahlen weil ich nur von
dieser einen person die disc bekommen
kann
die reddot user auf wallstreet mez
beginnen also ihr komplettes geld im
gamestop zu investieren oder wie sie es
sagen zu holen und der preis stand erst
auf 20 dann auf 35 dollar
immer mehr leute wurden darauf
aufmerksam die medien berichteten
darüber und sogar elon musk heizte die
aktien mit einem tweet an gleichzeitig
passiert ein spannender effekt die
shortseller also zum beispiel die
hedgefonds
covern ihre positionen kaufen also
aktien lieber zum jetzigen zeitpunkt
weil wer weiß wie teuer sie morgen sind
das kann eine kettenreaktion auslösen
bei der der preis in astronomische höhen
schießt denn jedes mal wenn ein short
seller seine position covert bedeutet
das eigentlich nur das wer aktien kauft
und das drückt den preis nach oben was
wiederum dafür sorgen kann dass der
nächste shortseller seine position
krawatte ein sogenannter short-squeeze
solches krise sind sehr selten
der wohl bekannteste war wohl der von vw
im jahr 2008 bei dem volkswagen für
kurze zeit das wertvollste unternehmen
der welt war
wenn man das erreichen kann dann müssen
die shortseller unglaubliche summen
bezahlen und wir auch immer dann seine
aktien verkauft der kann damit richtig
reich werden
letzte woche gab es dann den ersten
kleinen screens wenn auch keinen
richtigen short-squeeze der preis
praktisch beim auf 350 dollar fast das
hundertfache von dem was die partie nie
value vor über einem jahr bezahlt hat er
hat einen knapp 50 millionen dollar in
gamestop aktien und auch viele andere
user auf reddit bekommen wortwörtlich
über nacht die mensa summen geld sie
schreiben post dass sie sich endlich die
lebensrettende op für verwandte oder
ihren hund leisten können dass sie ihre
schulden abbezahlen können oder dass sie
aufhören können in ihren beschissenen
job zu arbeiten
andere sind auch einfach nur froh ist
der wallstreet endlich mal heim zahlen
zu können
sie sind wütend auf die spekulanten auf
die finanzkrise von 2008 auf verlorene
jobs und tatsächlich verliert alleine
ein hedgefonds 6 milliarden dollar die
hälfte seines vermögens ein sieg für
rettet und die kleinanleger
generell muss man aber in frage stellen
ob dieser kampf wirklich einer von klein
gegen groß von arm gegen reich von david
gegen goliath ist das habe ich in den
letzten tagen zwar fiel auf twitter
gelesen aber zum einen sind menschen die
mal eben ein paar tausend euro in
riskante aktien stecken können nicht
wirklich arm und zum anderen verdienen
auch manche hedgefonds gerade kräftig
mit
sie haben mitbekommen was rettet
probiert und auch groß im gamestop
investiert um davon zu profitieren
und man kann davon ausgehen dass diese
anderen hedge fonds er die aktien
verkaufen werden wenn alles vorbei ist
denn gamestop mag zwar nicht kurz vor
dem ende stehen aber sie sind auch
definitiv nicht über 300 dollar pro
aktie wert der preis muss irgendwann
wieder sinken und dann werden viele
leute die ihr erspartes in gangs topf
gesteckt haben
mit großen verlusten nach hause gehen
deswegen auch investiert jetzt bitte
nicht mehr in game store
es ist zu spät wenn man das vor ein oder
zwei wochen gemacht hätte dann hätte
sich das richtig gelohnt aber
einzusteigen wenn der preis hoch ist ist
keine gute idee
das soll natürlich nicht heißen dass es
nicht weiter nach oben gehen kann
der große short squeeze ist noch nicht
gekommen aber es ist unwahrscheinlich
zumindest in meinen augen dass da
überhaupt noch passiert denn es gibt
noch einen krassen tourist in dieser
geschichte
robin wood die app mit der fast alle
amerikanischen user auf wallstreet betz
ihrer aktien kaufen hat am donnerstag
das kaufen von gamestop aktien
kurzweilig verboten
robin hood nimmt von den armen und
schützt die reichen hedge fonds genau
andersherum als es der eigentliche robin
hood getan hätte denn wie sich
herausstellt macht robin hood den
großteil seines geldes indem es daten an
citadel securities weiter gibt einen
hedgefonds der richtig geraten gamestop
massiv geshortet hat kurz darauf folgten
dann auch eine menge andere apps hier in
deutschland zum beispiel trade republic
und spätestens hier wurden offizielle
institutionen auf die ganze situation
aufmerksam
dann schaut mal es wurde nur verboten
die aktie zu kaufen was den preis
steigen lassen würde preissenkende
verkäufe wurden weiterhin erlaubt das
ist marktmanipulation und da sind sie
sogar mal ausnahmsweise die beiden
großen politischen parteien in den usa
ein licht cruise hat er sie öffentlich
auf twitter zugestimmt was
ausnahmezustände
die generalstaatsanwälte von texas und
new york haben weiter angekündigt in
diesem fall zu ermitteln und es wird
vielleicht sogar eine anhörung des
financial services committee geben was
daraus wird das kann man jetzt noch
nicht sagen vielleicht gar nichts aber
es besteht die möglichkeit dass dieses
ereignis der auslöser dafür wird das
short selling in zukunft eingeschränkt
oder besser reguliert wird
und das alles weil ein youtuber auf
reddit an seine these geglaubt hat und
die aktien festgehalten hat
okay was lernen wir daraus auch wenn die
geschichte noch so schön wäre es
verdienen gerade nicht wirklich die
kleinen millionen während die
hedgefonds-manager milliardeneinbußen
vielmehr gibt es manche hedgefonds die
gewinnen und andere die verlieren
genauso wie es private anleger gibt's
die gerade kräftig gewinnen und welche
die ihr geld verlieren werden und dass
der markt durch diesen short-squeeze
zusammenbricht oder rettet die wall
street in die knie zwingt wie es manche
vorhersagen ist in meinen augen totaler
quatsch
aber vor allem erzählt uns diese
geschichte eine viel traurige wahrheit
der markt kann manipuliert werden egal
ob es die großen hedgefonds oder jetzt
zum ersten mal die privaten anleger
machen
gamestop sparer wert liegt niemals so
hoch das ist reine spekulation
der aktienmarkt hat oft wenig mit der
echten marktwirtschaft zu tun
es ist ein ort an dem leute ihr geld
warten und hoffen es zu vervielfachen
ohne dabei irgendetwas wirklich
produktives zu tun
es ist in vielerlei hinsicht ein casino
mit dem großen unterschied dass die
auswirkungen hier die echte welt und
andere menschen beeinflussen können und
es sind fast immer die negativen
auswirkungen ein paar banken verzocken
sich zac wirtschaftskrise und millionen
von menschen verlieren ihre jobs und
2008 passiert unter anderem meiner mama
aber andersherum globale pandemie und
millionen menschen verlieren ihre jobs
kein problem all time high an der börse
wenn ihr euch jetzt ein wenig von dieser
realität ablenken wollte dann kann ich
euch ein paar gute dokumentarfilme
empfehlen
ihr erinnert euch vielleicht dass wir
vor einigen wochen unsere eigene website
doktor watson tv gestartet haben wo ihr
euch ganz viele richtig gute
dokumentarfilme ansehen könnt die wir
persönlich ausgewählt haben zum beispiel
planet stack herausforderung zukunft
oder future by starck und seit unserem
lorch sind auch schon ein paar neue
dokus dazu gekommen unter anderem die
genetische revolution wo auch endlich
mal die philosophischen und die
umweltaspekte von christa kessler
beleuchtet werden
schaut euch mal um auf doktor watson
punkt tv link ist in der video
beschreibung und abonniert unser angebot
wenn ihr uns unterstützen wollt das
ganze kostet fünf euro im monat denn wir
haben leider nicht im gamestop aktien
investiert
vielen dank fürs zuschauern bleibt die
immer neugierig bleibt gesund war cedric